bonjour
je suis hugo benoît je travaille dans
cité à travers ma société bridgepoint
qui réalise de la protection
informations à 360 degrés face à des
menaces hybride il y a une phrase dans
la sécurité informatique que l'on entend
est souvent qui dit que la sécurité est
un échec on dit ça car on évolue dans un
cercle vicieux où les attaquants ont
toujours un temps d'avancé sur les
défenseurs qui deviennent sans cesse
obsolète on peut considérer la sécurité
comme une assurance c'est quand il ya un
problème que l'on sait pourquoi on en a
besoin et pourquoi on paye des gens
comme moi
ça c'est mon quotidien
mais à côté de cela j'ai fondé plusieurs
communautés de milliers de personnes de
plusieurs milliers de personnes
sur la cybersécurité notamment quelque
chose qu'on appelle loathing le
renseignement d'origine sources ouvertes
en français et ses communautés vise
avant tout à promouvoir la diffusion de
connaissances dans ces domaines ceci
afin de permettre aux individus d'être
davantage des acteurs de la société
d'information lutter contre l'effet news
ou apprendre à chercher correctement de
l'information
souvent dans l'espace numérique on en
pense que tout est permis comme un jeu
on est totalement libre et anonyme et
cela se traduit par l'idée d'agir dans
des conflits et de d'agir un peu comme
si on avait carte blanche sans limite et
sans conséquence
ceci est illusoire car l'esprit l'espace
numérique impacte le réel que ce soit
des cyber attaques qui visent des
infrastructures stratégiques comme des
centrales électriques dans des conflits
armés ou des gens qui subissent du
cyberharcèlement il y a un impact sur le
réel
or notre liberté s'arrête là où celle de
l'autre commence c'est un précepte
ancestrale que tout le monde connaît son
touch qui induit une notion d'éthique
pourquoi car c'est parce que j'ai une
considération de l'autre que j'existe en
tant qu'homme libre et digne et que je
permet à la société de faire sens
c'est pour cela que je viens vous parler
d'éthique car dans le hacking comme dans
la vie de tous les jours nos choix nos
actions ont le sens que l'on donne par
rapport à autrui
c'est ainsi c'est ainsi que dans un
milieu du hac on parle de white hat de
black hat qui sont les bons à coeur d'un
côté et ce qui est de la société en fait
et ce et qui ont une éthique qui
permettent d'aider dre les individus et
ce qui suit au contraire ne voient que
leurs intérêts personnels
et
qui tendent à détruire la stabilité du
monde d'un certain
fonder une communauté en ligne
ou dans le rappel le réel enfin une
communauté de d'humain
ne peut se faire que le record soit
respectent des règles des comportements
et des attitudes par rapport à autrui
mais aussi voilà c'est ça se fait dans
le rapport à la loi et dans le rapport à
autrui
aristote disait que l'homme est un
animal politique
alors il ne parlait pas de parti
politique de main tendue
c'est le sens du bien commun en fait qui
permet de et du collectif qui nous
distingue des animaux c'est parce que
j'ai un rapport à l'autre l'état animal
c'est l'état de nature c'est là où le
plus petit et le plus faible
se voit contraindre par le plus fort et
le plus grand
c'est un long débat entre une vision un
peu plus anglo-saxonne d'une société
autoritaire avec up ce qu'ils pensent
que l'homme est un loup pour l'homme et
donc il faut un état puissant qu'il
appelle lui le léviathan
afin de contraindre les hommes à éviter
de s'autodétruire et notre vision qui
est celle des lumières une vision
française avec rousseau par exemple où
l'homme serait plutôt bon par nature et
c'est la société qui construit pour se
défaire de son état nature qui le
corrompt
nous ne résoudrons pas ce très très très
long débat
ici mais dans les deux cas en fait les
deux visions de ce qu'est l'homme c'est
la communauté des hommes en fait qui
détache
qui ne détache des déterminismes naturel
c'est parce quand il ya une société ces
communautés des hommes ont dans la
vision occidentale moderne deux
objectifs celui de rendre des individus
libres et plus en sécurité non pas en
ayant carte blanche comme on l'a dit
précédemment mais en se positionnant
comme des citoyens responsables et en
obéissant à des lois et rien qu'aux lois
quand elles sont justes et à condition
que chacun y est ils obéissent
alors quel est le lien avec liking me
direz vous c'est que dans le hacking le
hacking c'est un peu comme l'art en fait
c'est le dépassement de la norme c'est
la possibilité de dépasser le sens
commun d'un usage d'une pratique ou d'un
outil c'est une façon de se libérer du
sens préalable et préétablis d'une chose
c'est pourquoi dans notre société
technologique dans laquelle nous
évoluons il est important de savoir
maîtriser
l'information et les instruments qui les
mobilise
le concept du hacker comme
qui traverse les frontières sans sans
répondre de ses actes avec beaucoup de
crypto monnaie des millions de crypto
monnaie avec lui qui
qui se moque des lois qui est des gens
est un mythe totalement imaginaire et
qu'on retrouve dans les cinémas ou
autres éléments
par exemple lorsqu'on voit que le fbi à
y arrive à identifier des acteurs
étatiques en corée du nord sachant qu'en
corée du nord on ne voyage pas trop à
l'extérieur et il est plus on y rentre
pas trop non plus on peut légitimement
se demander si qui n'est pas
identifiable pour les autorités qui se
donne le temps et les moyens
les hackers russophone qui sont
coupables d' attaque qu'on appelle de
rang somewhere c'est-à-dire qu'ils
piratent lettre les serveurs chiffres
toutes les données et demandent une
rançon à la fin
leurs cibles sont des institutions des
entreprises des hôpitaux
et bien ces hackers sont contraints de
ne plus voyager à l'étranger ils doivent
payer des fortunes ou collaborer avec
les autorités locales pour leur
protection ils vont devoir mentir à
leurs proches se méfier de leurs voisins
ils ne dormiront sans doute pas très
tranquillement parce qu'ils savent que
ce qu'ils gagnent et les bénéfices qui
tiers de leur méfait est temporaire ça
peut s'arrêter n'importe quand
cette instabilité
c'est contre 1 pouces bien qu'en
agissant hors de l'éthique les black
cats
perdre leur liberté et qui ne sont donc
de facto exclus de la communauté des
hommes
donc les tic dans le hacking et est
quand même un élément salvateur pour
ceux qui l'appliquent elle leur donne la
ligne directrice à suivre est la ligne
rouge à ne pas franchir
afin de continuer d'évoluer dans un
esprit libertaire et en aimant six
batteurs
donc souvent ce qu'on appelle les gars
femmes c'est à dire google facebook
microsoft ont tenté de diffuser un
message justement libertaire avec une
démarche qui se voulait cool et branché
ainsi il pouvait libérer les hommes de
chercher l'amour avec kinder libérer les
hommes de faire soi même ses courses
avec amber
libérer les hommes de retenir des choses
puisque google le fait à votre place et
il suffit de chercher dans google
mais si on peut légitimement se demander
alors si les technologies font tout à ma
place alors que me reste-t-il en tant
qu'individu
et si on fait le bilan de la
mondialisation technologique telle qu'on
la connaît c'est souvent de l'écologie
et la biodiversité qui sont vues comme
en extinction
mais c'est aussi notre culture nos
habitudes notre vision du monde qui
est réduite peu à peu qui est uniformisé
et autres c'est la diversité de l'homme
qu'on tue à petit feu en fait gunther
enders un trafic losophe allemand du 20e
siècle a écrit dans son ouvrage qui
s'appelle l'obsolescence de l'homme
plusieurs idées et dont une qui pense
que les individus de la société de
l'information verront leurs
particularismes s'éteindre au crépuscule
des outils de communication qui seront
aunisiens
autrement dit les médias de masse créer
une culture de masse
qui ne peut que devenir à terme la norme
pour tous
ainsi sur 7000 langues qui sont
actuellement parlées dans le monde
il en restera
au moins de la moitié d'ici la fin du
siècle
alors quel idéal se raccrocher ou plutôt
quelle éthique doit dicter mes choix
pour ne pas être esclave d'un système
sensé me libérer alors qu'en réalité ils
m'étouffe
plusieurs systèmes pilot de plusieurs
systèmes philosophiques et bien je sais
questionnement ainsi le plus puissant
actuellement venue des états unis qui
est celui à mon humble avis un grand
danger pour l'homme
je veux parler de transhumanisme
il est souvent entre mener au courant
qu'on appelle libertariens c'est à dire
les anarchistes mais de droite
et est constitué la base du soutien de
trump par exemple dans certains
événements
il est souvent tu vois là
et pour ces courants là en fait ce
mouvement souhaite l'avènement d'un post
humain un individu augmenté par les
technologies qui dépasserait les règles
de la nature immortel et absolue il ne
répondra plus des choses primitive mais
des outils modernes joli programme me
direz vous mais la question se pose pour
qui ce destin et il regarde on par
exemple le dernier iphone qui peut se
l'acheter à sa sortie qu'il a en avant
première tout le monde a un téléphone
ici dans la salle mais combien parmi
vous ont le dernier modèle combien de
gamme différente de téléphone il existe
parmi vous et bien en fait
on pourrait se demander légitimement qui
pourraient s'acheter un cerveau bionique
qui pourra trompé la mort en se faisant
pousser
qu'est l'humanité sera physiquement
supérieur est invincible face aux gens
du peuple qui ne seront que de modestes
humain
et bien comme par hasard ce sont les
mêmes qui font les technologies des
élites transhumanistes sur ceux qui
dirigent généralement les sociétés
qui sont liées aux nouvelles
technologies de l'information et de la
communication
ainsi ces derniers
payent plus sur la matière les outils
pour l'avenir que sur les règles du
vivant ils privilégient l'intérêt privé
sur le bien commun puisqu'ils savent
très bien qu'une petite élite pourra
subsister à ces évolutions techniques
mais aussi ils préfèrent consommer le
monde
plutôt que d'être acteur responsable du
bien commun et des générations futures
alors est ce là les tic qui nous
sauverait est ce que cela est ce que
cela l'alternative au déterminisme de
l'esclavagisme moderne
je ne pense pas du tout c'est au
contraire une position politique qui ne
sert pas du tout le collectif et si vous
avez suivi depuis le début cela ne fait
de nous des animaux car nous aurions
accord bionique donc non humains et on
ne serait pas un animal politique car ne
soyons pas politique puisqu'il n'y
aurait pas d'amour du bien commun
puisque ça serait une minorité qui
profiteraient de tout ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier de me compoint a qualifié en
fait d'une mauvaise éthique par rapport
aux à la question technologique elle
ferait de nous des non humains au sens
propre comme figuré
ce n'est donc pas forcément la voie la
plus belle la plus juste la plus vraie
pour l'avenir de l'humanité
alors faut-il rejeté en bloc les
technologies comme le font les par
exemple les courants primitiviste
faudrait-il un retour aux choses de la
terre
cultiver son jardin comme disait
voltaire faudrait-il ne pas se soucier
du monde extérieur
bon pourtant on serait bien content
d'avoir le monde moderne si un jour un
membre de notre famille tombe malade ou
d'avoir plusieurs outils pour par
exemple se nourrir correctement
s'écarter de la civilisation moderne
pourrait paraître attirant mais le monde
est finie et l'élan du progrès ne nous
attend pas ainsi cette fuite et ce
retrait du monde moderne ne se ferait
que creuser l'écart et de la distinction
entre le reste de la population
technologiques et les gens qui la
refusent
alors que faire
comment se libérer
gardez une éthique positive et évoluer
dans un cyber monde
qui bouge sans cesse ce sont des
questions que je me suis posée que j'ai
partagé avec vous et qui m'ont poussé
voilà à m'interroger à me remettre en
question sur mes propres pratiques
ça m'a permis de me poser des questions
mais aussi d'agir c'est pour cela que
j'ai construit des communautés de
diffusion du savoir sur ces technologies
et sur le monde de l'eau zink ou du
hacking pour permettre ce qu'appelle
certains une forme d'éducation populaire
sur les technologies informatiques
car à mon sens c'est bien la
connaissance et la maîtrise de
l'information qui libéra des hommes et
en fera des citoyens responsables du au
nom de la liberté l'égalité et de la
fraternité merci
[Applaudissements]